[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
der idyllische Ammersee am 15 September
1981 ein zehnjähriges Mädchen wird vom
Fahrrad gerissen in eine Kiste gesperrt
vergraben und stirbt jahrelang bleibt
das Verbrechen ungesund aber dann wird
ein Nachbar überführt und eingesperrt
war das ein Fehlurteil waren in Wahrheit
zwei Oberstufenschüler die Täter der
eine ein Kind eines einflussreichen
Geschäftsmann ist mit Verbindungen in
die Politik wurden sie deshalb sogar von
höchster Stelle gedeckt der Fall Ursula
Herrmann ist für die Justiz gelöst der
Täter hat seine Strafe sogar schon
abgesessen aber für den wegen
erpresserischen Menschen Raubs mit
Todesfolge Verurteilten heute
74-Jährigen und seinen Anwalt ist es ein
cold-case sie kämpfen für eine
Wiederaufnahme der Mann heißt Werner mal
Zurek Bild hat ihn unter anderem im
April diesen Jahres im Gefängnis besucht
dort sagte er im Gespräch mit
bild-reporterin Lena Dezember ich bin ja
ich kann das Wort ja nicht mehr hören
ich bin unschuldig Punkt
[Musik]
bin Toni Heyer und mit mir ist wie immer
Mirko Kasimir hallo Mirko hi grüß Dich
Toni und hallo an alle da draußen schön
dass ihr dabei seid und herzlich
willkommen hier bei Tatort Deutschland
zusammen erzählen wir euch heute warum
es so viele Fragezeichen gibt in diesem
Fall der doch eigentlich längst geklärt
ist aber die wichtigste Person in dieser
Doppelfolge ist mal wieder
bild-reporterin Lena Zander sie hat
diesen Mordfall in den letzten Monaten
komplett neu aufgerollt
und zwar war das 1981 der erste Schultag
nach den Sommerferien Ursula war nach
der Schule noch bei naturnstunde dann
hat sie ihre Cousine besucht und
anschließend radelt sie wie immer am
Ammersee das Stück nach Hause aber zu
Hause ist Ursula Hermann gar nicht erst
angekommen ihre Eltern machen sich
Sorgen melden Sie als vermisst und erste
Wochen später wird Ursula Herrmann
gefunden und zwar begraben in dem
Waldstück am Ammersee im Weingarten in
einer Holzkiste
dieses Jahr 1981 gehört zu einer
spannenden Zeit der Kalte Krieg steuert
mit der atomaren Aufrüstung auf seinen
nächsten Höhepunkt zu Bundeskanzler
Schmidt regiert ein Deutschland in dem
immer wieder hunderttausende für den
Frieden auf die Straße gehen im fernen
Afghanistan kämpfen seit zwei Jahren
Sowjets gegen die lokale Regierung aber
für Familie Hermann in Eching am
bayerischen Ammersee spielt das in
diesem Sommer alles keine Rolle sie
bankt wochenlang um das Leben ihrer
Tochter Lena Zander Blick zurück in der
Zeit wo Ursula verschwunden war
flatterten zwei Erpresserbriefe bei der
Familie Hermann ein so ausgeschnitten
aus Buchstaben aus der Zeitung und da
drin forderten der oder die Erpresser 2
Millionen D-Mark Lösegeld wo man sich
schon fragt Ursula Hermanns Familie war
nicht so wohlhabend in dieser Ecke haben
viel wohlhabende Kinder gelebt und auch
viele Eltern gelebt die Geld hatten
warum Familie Herrmann
die so auf die Schnelle gar keine zwei
Millionen D-Mark hatte
mehrmals klingelt in dieser Zeit das
Telefon bei den Hermanns aber am anderen
Ende sagt niemand was stattdessen
schweigen und das verkehrssignal des
Senders Bayern 3
[Musik]
die Polizei hört mit und sie lässt immer
wieder das Waldstück am Ammersee
durchsuchen in dem Ursula verschwand den
sogenannten Weingarten und schließlich
wird das Versteck gefunden eine Kiste im
Waldboden die viele höher ist als breit
und da ist Perfide an dieser Geschichte
ist die Holzkiste war 139 cm hoch 72 cm
breit und 60 cm tief also Ursula konnte
in dieser Holzkiste auch sitzen und ihr
Entführer hatten auch Lebensmittel in
die Kiste gelegt hatten Bücher
reingelegt die war beleuchtet und auch
in selbst gebautes Belüftungssystem oben
angebracht aber das Belüftungssystem
versagte als die Kiste geöffnet wird
finden Sie die Leiche des Mädchens in
der Kiste waren untereinander natürlich
Wasser Bücher
Butterkekse und sogar ein Eimer wo
Ursula Herrmann ihre Notdurft verrichten
konnte die Kiste war auch beleuchtet
dafür war eine Autobatterie
angeschlossen worden es gab auch ein
Brettchen in dieser Holzkiste auf dem
das Mädchen sitzen konnte es gab Comics
es gab Romane alles mögliche so dass man
nachher auch gesagt hat der Entführer
oder die Entführer hatten gar nicht vor
das Mädchen zu töten weil sehr
Vorkehrung getroffen hatten dass das
Mädchen überlebt gerade mit dem
Belüftungssystemen sind selbst gebautes
Belüftungssystem was dann aus der Erde
ragte und oberhalb der Kiste angebracht
war sprich dafür dass das Mädchen
überleben sollte deswegen ist der
Straftat bestand auch später nicht Mord
gewesen wer hat die zehnjährige Ursula
entführt also ich meine das muss man
sich vorstellen jemand hat eine
riesengroße Kiste gebaut mit einem
Belüftungssystem und tief in den
Waldboden vergraben jemand hat das Kind
vom Rad gestoßen und mehrere hundert
Meter von dieser Stelle bis zum
versteckt waren es also vielleicht
mehrere Täter
im kleinen Ort Eching am Ammersee mit
seinen knapp 1.800 Einwohnern wird
bildlich gesprochen jeder Stein
umgedreht und tatsächlich schält sich
aus hunderten Befragungen schließlich
etwas mehr als ein halbes Jahr später
ein Verdächtiger heraus der örtliche
fernsehelektriker Werner matsurek den
kennt im Ort fast jeder mal zurecht lebt
unweites Tatorts und viele halten ihn
für einen unsympathischen Stinkstiefel
er hat mal Leuten erzählt dass er seinen
Hund in eine Kühltruhe steckte und das
Tier darin vergast bis es starb aber das
ist nicht der Grund warum die Spur zu
ihm zeitweise als sehr heiß gibt Mats
zurück wird nämlich von einem anderen
Echinger schwer belastet ein bekannter
Mann zuerst der inzwischen verstorbene
Klaus Pfaffinger sagt im Februar 1982
bei der Polizei aus er habe das Loch für
die Kiste im Auftrag von mazed gegraben
Lena Zander
bei den Ermittlungen ist glaube ich viel
schief gelaufen auch zu Anfang Zeit man
muss sich das vorstellen dass es
heutzutage gar nicht mehr möglich als
die Kiste gefunden wurde sind zum
Beispiel Helfer fremde Menschen in diese
Kiste rein haben das Mädchen daraus
geholt sprich Spuren auch vernichtet und
Werner matsurek ein Nachbar der Familie
und ein Fernsehtechniker im Ort der galt
schon sehr früh als Verdächtiger man hat
seine Werkstatt durchsucht geschaut ob
er diese Kiste vielleicht selbst gebaut
hat man hat ihn gefragt was er zu dem
Tatzeitpunkt gemacht hat und man hat
auch mit einem Bekannten von ihm
gesprochen mit dem Klaus Pfaffinger und
Klaus Pfaffinger hat bei der Polizei
ausgesagt dass Werner Mats zurück ihnen
beauftragt hätte das Loch für die Kiste
im Weingarten zu graben was aber sehr
merkwürdig ist ist diese Aussage ist
nicht schriftlich in den Polizeiakten
festgehalten worden und Klaus Pfaffinger
hat diese Aussage auch ganz schnell
wieder rufen lena hat es schon gesagt
die Aussage mit der Beschuldigung wurde
nicht festgehalten aber die Widerrufung
schon jedes nachgesprochene Protokoll er
hat zunächst den vernehmungswagen
Vorhalt sie haben im Vorgespräch
allerdings und das seit zugegeben auf
unsere drängenden Fragen schließlich
geantwortet sie hätten das Loch im
Weingarten in dem die Kiste der Ursula
Herrmann versteckt worden ist im Auftrag
des matzurek gegraben und er habe ihnen
dafür 1000 D-Mark und ein
Farbfernsehgerät versprochen dies möchte
ich widerrufen es war nicht wahr was ich
da erzählt habe ich weiß auch nicht
warum ich Mats zurück beschuldigt habe
an dieser Stelle erkläre ich noch mal
dass er mich nie aufgefordert hat für
ihn ein Loch zu graben und dass ich
solches auch nie getan habe
Klaus Pfaffinger da gibt es auch ein
Gutachten drüber war Alkoholiker und
Klaus Pfaffinger konnte auch gar nicht
den Ort der Kiste zeigen also die
Polizisten sind ja mit ihm ins Auto
während dieser Befragung im Februar 82
sind mit ihm in den Weingarten gefahren
haben gesagt wo hast du die Kiste
vergraben er konnte das gar nicht zeigen
und man muss sich mal vorstellen ein
Mann ein Alkoholiker der so ein tiefes
Loch alleine gräbt wie will der da auch
wieder rausgekommen sein auch eine Frage
die nicht beantwortet wurde
die Spur zu Mazurek und die spannende
aber widerrufene Aussage pfaffingers
führen also erstmal ins Nichts die
Polizei ermittelt weiter sie lässt aber
erst zwei Jahre nach dem Verbrechen
Fingerabdrücke im Landheim Ammersee
nehmen das ist ein Internat an dem die
Schüler ihr Abitur machen darunter viele
Kinder reicher und wichtiger Leute
kleiner Tipp merkt euch dieses Landheim
für Teil 2 aber erstmal bringen auch
diese Ermittlungen keinen Fortschritt
der Fall Ursula Herrmann wird zum Cold
Case und Werner matsurek also der Kauz
mit der fernseh-reparaturwerkstatt der
zieht weg von Bayern nach Kappeln in
Schleswig-Holstein 27 Jahre bleibt der
Fall ungelöst als Ermittler ihn wieder
aus dem Aktenschrank holen ist es dieses
Detail das den Durchbruch bringt
[Musik]
die verkehrsmusik von Bayern 3 denn als
Kripo-Beamte die Wohnung von Werner
Mazurek in Norddeutschland durchsuchen
fällt Ihnen ein altes Tonbandgerät auf
bald sind sie sicher das ist der Apparat
mit dem Mazurek 1981 das
radiojingle-aufnahmen und dann eben bei
seinen Anrufen bei den Hermanns
abspielen im Gespräch mit Bild in der
JVA Lübeck erinnert sich mal zurück an
den Tag der Hausdurchsuchung ich dachte
schon wieder Zeugen Jehovas oder wer da
immer kommt am Sonntag dürfen wir mal
reinkommen und
Durchsuchungsbeschluss vorgezeigt die
ganze Bruder auf dem Kopf gestellt der
alte tonbandapparat bringt also den
Durchbruch wobei Mats diesen
Zusammenhang gegenüber der Polizei als
absurd bezeichnet er habe das Gerät
nämlich erst viele Jahre nach dem Tod
von Ursula Herrmann auf einem Flohmarkt
in Norddeutschland gekauft ja aber von
wem denn will die Polizei wissen das
weiß ich leider nicht mehr genau muss
matsurek einräumen aber die Justiz zeigt
sich davon unbeeindruckt Lena Zander
dieses Tonbandgerät und das widerrufene
Geständnis von Klaus Pfaffinger schon
aus den 80er Jahren waren die
wesentliche Bestandteile für die Anklage
später gegen Werner matsurek und auch
gegen seine damalige Ehefrau seine
Ehefrau wurde freigesprochen und Werner
matsurek wurde zu lebenslange Haft
verurteilt was man vielleicht aber auch
noch erwähnen sollte ist dieses
tonbandgutachten was bei Gericht so viel
Gewicht gehabt hat sagt dass es nur
wahrscheinlich ist dass dieses
Tonbandgerät das Gerät ist von dem das
BAYERN 3 Signal abgespielt wurde ich
habe darüber mit Joachim Feller
gesprochen das ist der Anwalt von
Michael Hermann das ist der Bruder von
Ursula Hermann und der ordnete mir das
ein und sagt das ist wie eine Schulnote
3 wahrscheinlich also kann man noch
nicht mal sagen das ist es gewesen
ihr hört schon bei Lena dass die Sache
mit dem Tonband umstritten ist aber der
Justiz reicht es
2010 verurteilt das Landgericht Augsburg
also Werner matsurek zu lebenslanger
Haft bei dem Urteil spielt sogar die
alte Beschuldigung von matsurex
bekannten Pfaffinger eine Rolle der ist
längst tot und kann dazu gar nicht mehr
gehört werden die Aktendeckel werden
wieder zugeklappt der Fall Ursula
Herrmann ist gelöst für Werner matsurek
steht aber vom ersten Tag der Haft an
fest ich kämpfe weiter für meine
Unschuld so sagte es im bildgespräch im
April 2023
bis heute seine Unschuld und er hat zu
mir gesagt dass er unbedingt diesen
Menschen finden möchte der ihn das
Tonbandgerät verkauft hat weil er sagt
er hat das Tonbandgerät 2007 auf einem
Flohmarkt in Niedersachsen gekauft
das heißt wenn es wirklich stimmen würde
könnte das Tonbandgerät gar nicht das
gewesen sein was 1981 in seinem Besitz
war und von dem er aus das Signal
abgespielt haben soll aber der große
bärtige Mann mit der tropfenbrille der
schafft es während seiner Haft nicht
dass jemand seinen Fall wieder aufnimmt
er sitzt erstmal in der JVA Augsburg ein
später in Lübeck als bildreporterin Lena
Zander ihn dort besucht erzählt er dass
er in U-Haft in Augsburg um das Jahr
2009 herum einen ehemals Prominenten und
dubiosen Geschäftsmann kennenlernte der
Mann saß zur selben Zeit wie man zurück
in der JVA Augsburg ein wartete auf
seinen Prozess wegen Steuerhinterziehung
wir waren auf der Krankenabteilung sagt
Mats zurück im Gespräch mit Lena dort
hätten sie auch über den Fall Ursula
Herrmann gesprochen Mats zurück zitiert
den Mann so
wir haben das durchdiskutiert und die
ermittlungspanne durchgesprochen ich
weiß du warst es nicht
also das ist natürlich fraglich ob sich
da jetzt jemand die abenteuerlichsten
Geschichten ausdenkt um seine Unschuld
zu untermauern aber wie ihr in Teil 2
hören werdet führt das knastgespräch mit
dem Geschäftsmann tatsächlich zu
hochinteressanten Fragen hat die Polizei
die Spur vom Landschulheim damals in den
80ern nicht ernst genug genommen wurde
Ursula Herrmann nicht von Werner matsure
getötet sondern von anderen Tätern von
mehreren oder war es sogar ein Polizist
das und eine man muss das Sagen
peinliche spurenpanne die hörte in der
Fortsetzung wir freuen uns wenn ihr
morgen wieder einschaltet eure Tony und
eure Mirko